no no um it's a real red flag um
i would say like
if they're talking about their past
relationships and like everything is the
girl's fault or like the girls crazy
i'm like okay so either you like crazy
women okay
which isn't that's not good
i'm like then offensive why are you out
with me
or two or two like like you're probably
a cheat like because in my mind it's
like oh he's probably a cheater because
why are all these girls going crazy like
because i have brothers they date
and their girlfriends don't go crazy on
them because they're not they're not
cheaters
i have a question you said something
interesting yeah you like
you're like oh the second thing is that
he's probably a cheater because he made
them crazy
if it's a pattern one off that's one
thing but if it's a pattern you're the
common denominator
but why would you
why would you say
that if they're all crazy
it's because of him why is that even an
option why because i would say the same
thing for a girl so you would say if a
girl was like to you like every guy i've
been with has been abusive to me you'd
be like well what the [ __ ] did you do
yes i swear to god yes yes
i mean i might say to her face but i'm
thinking it like what did you do like i
just wanna i just wanna clarify if you
go through life and you have the same
patterns in all of your relationships
like how can you not
i just i just wanna clarify right
because this might get you some in some
hot water okay okay
you're saying that there's a possibility
that if a girl gets abused it's her own
fault
yeah because some girls some girls
attack the guys first no no yeah if she
gives you i know but so so if it's
either like there's either two issues
with her she's either she picks guys
that are abusers why are you picking men
that are it's the same thing i would say
the same way why are you picking men
that are abusers because and
like i've been in like a bad
relationship before where like i would
say he was crazy it was my own damn
fault like
what was not every relationship but like
you know what i'm saying like i feel
like you should take accountability for
who you pick no i no i i agree with you
yeah but like you said that was the
first option right so the first option
you're like okay
clearly he's choosing wrong yeah then
you said the second option you're like
oh he's triggered them to behave this
way yeah and you think that's a thing
yes i think like
yeah like if a guy feels like a trigger
if a guy if a guy's cheated on every
single girl that he's been like like of
course they're gonna act crazy and i do
i think like i think the girl should
probably just leave but as a woman like
we kind of know that like like what are
you doing
i disagree with that i don't think i
know there's this whole thing of you
know women are
you know generally more emotional than
men
but
this whole thing of being like when a
girl goes
oh he made me crazy or he made her crazy
i just think that's just massive
[ __ ] like you are
you're control you're in control of your
own actions and you can you can leave
the environment you can leave the
situation i i agree
i like i agree with you like i think in
an ideal world like you should leave but
that doesn't always happen because i
just think guys can't use that excuse oh
well she just made me crazy so i decked
her in the throat like guys oh but i
wasn't talking about decking in the
throat that's like when i
when i thought crazy i just thought like
she's always asking where i am or like
she's looking through my phone that's
what i was thinking i wasn't oh no i
never i would never crazy like she's
like thrown [ __ ] cuz oh no i would never
never never in a million years advocate
like that that's something okay okay
so it is your ability to pick though
yeah it is 100
oh no i was going to say i would jump in
here and say literally i was like
literally i could have kissed you right
then
that that is
equally what i would say the red flag
for me if a guy says his girlfriend is
like specifically psycho [ __ ] those are
literal words i've heard before always
it's always the guys that cheat it's
always a voice that's always nice and
cheap but
and this is the thing man does something
wrong woman holds him accountable woman
is then a psycho [ __ ] and like that
isn't the trend sometimes sometimes the
one thing i would say
is like
the i so i agree with the first part of
what you said i would disagree with the
latter part about to do with sometimes
it's the woman's fault if someone or
like is the person's fault if they're
being abused i would say for sure so
that's their fault for picking them like
it's the same pattern for sure i would
say that sometimes people have a pattern
of picking abuses but i think a lot of
the time people who have been raised in
abusive
surroundings i'm just that thing because
that is what and i think sometimes i
think people sometimes people are really
deceptive there have been cases of
marrying someone who as soon as they're
married they completely
i've just found those like if there's a
pattern of behavior like a lot of times
like girls won't talk about what they
did first
so like yeah maybe he like did something
but like
that i never would advocate for a guy to
hit well
even look at it for girls watching this
she's very cute
so that's a that's a big yikes for me
if a girl is threatening a guy with a
wife a knife
or something like that that's what i was
thinking okay okay yeah yeah yeah that's
all right that's what i was thinking
like like if if a girl
was your thing shut up
why would i but then we're talking about
but then we're talking about a woman
who's instigating abuse because they're
being abusive
but i think why do we assume that like
the woman like she could have started it
okay yeah she could have by being
abusive in the first place right we're
not talking about domestic abuse victims
but we're talking about someone in a in
a right equally toxic and abusive
relationship i think it can be both i
think yeah that's definitely a thing but
i think it's dangerous territory
territory to wander into the well maybe
she maybe it's justified maybe she
deserved it and i think or maybe he
deserved it or maybe he deserves it yeah
yeah yeah this is also another thing of
of women that was a really good
documentary on the bbc i mean i think
you have to question like people that
bring that stuff forward like either way
like if they're gonna press charges or
something they have to
like question that yeah you have to you
of course you have to look at all the
evidence yeah i guess i just come from a
standpoint of
i've seen women who have been in those
relationships yeah and nine times out of
ten more than nine times out of ten 99
of the time
it's genuinely that you know they've not
held a knife to their guy's throat and
again i think this is where the physical
dominance comes into a relationship of
like i am intrinsically always going to
feel more vulnerable around like take
you for example all right you are way
taller than me okay physically okay
regardless of my strength my strength
training historically
you could overpower me so easily
like and i think guys know that in a
relationship with a woman you're an
idiot if you don't and women are aware
of that in a relationship and i think it
it starts to wander into dangerous
territory when we start to say um
did they do something to deserve this
and where do we draw the line with that
do we draw the line with that with rape
did they do something to deserve this do
they instigate it in some way but like
that's you have to like the police have
to also do you know because you can't
give someone the power to just and i
think it's actually the same thing in
society like you have to question people
when they bring something forward
because you don't ever want to give
someone this like the power to ruin
someone's reputation with just accusing
them of something that could have been
completely false there has to be
evidence yeah you you have to
investigate it i guess my point is where
does that line of questioning come from
and where does that bleed into society
does it come from a point of because i
intrinsically disbelieve you because all
women are trying to ruin men's lives or
does it come from a point of i need to
know this evidence because i'm a
prosecutor well it's innocent until
proven guilty yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but you realize like society favors
women like they say believe all women
even though women be crazy like
no i'm saying like there are crazy girls
that lie about [ __ ] and like ruin men's
lives like they go to jail or even if
they don't do that like a girl can ruin
a guy's reputation with just an
accusation okay but look at look at the
amount of men okay within england i
think it's some